[Music]
in no bucks given news
submitted by spider toby a surfer got
attacked by a shark and went to a bar
instead of a hospital
that's what the [ __ ] i'm talking about
that's my people that's what i'm talking
about
what the [ __ ] is what no because
okay so off camera casey was telling me
all right this next article
see if you could channel like uh don't
be a [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm like when you're
bit by a shark i don't know how you
could be like
i'm not gonna be a [ __ ] [ __ ] well
that's very you i could see how he could
draw that conclusion
if i was bit by a [ __ ] shark what
what's the craziest thing he's done that
he was like
so he was learning how to do backflips
he break he fractures his foot
um and he's in a crazy pain and he goes
oh really foot
you're gonna be a [ __ ] [ __ ] right
now so he did like 20 more backflips
to prove his foot wrong you know what
was right i understand that that
fractured my foot and it does feel like
you could just walk it off and then it
you never walk it off
and he he like was like oh really
because you know how he does that [ __ ]
with his hands
oh really foot you're going to be a
[ __ ] [ __ ] watch and then he did
i did more backflips and what was funny
is i did more uh backflips while i was
crying
because when i fractured it it hurt so
bad that i hadn't i had tears
i had tears coming down i was like oh
[ __ ] don't be a [ __ ]
bart you might have gotten a guinness
world record for the most backflips
while crying with tears
yeah i've never heard that so you still
can't tap into that mindset
a shark oh we're crazy
all right what kind of shark uh a little
nurse yeah what if it was a little baby
shark
a little nurse shark like a little
six-inch thing
they're saying that it was a three to
four foot spinner or black tip shark
i'd go to a bar too not a great white
it's not a great way we're we're
thinking jaws where's it got like 18
teeth
yeah i'm thinking like you know a
cartoon bite where it looks like
a little piece is missing oh yeah nikki
you know me i probably wouldn't know the
hospital after that getting him bit by a
little
[ __ ] shark it depends on the blood
loss true i already went to the hospital
getting a little these
little [ __ ] you guys will never know
that pain i hope you never know that
i hope i've never known that paint's
here it probably wasn't that bad this is
a black tip shark
looks pretty query of me where did this
happen how did it happen and what's up
all right so this happened in florida
always in florida what the [ __ ] for
this guy he's a surfer he's a
professional surfer his name is frank
he's 23 years old
and he was surfing off of jacksonville
beach
and he said that like his f his friends
were filming
in the distance it's really grainy it's
not even worth showing you but they're
saying that in the
video you could see that there was like
a moment of struggle and then he gets
out and he's like still like carrying
his board and he's just like yeah think
i got i got bit
but he was just like okay on his arm
yeah on his elbow so they're saying that
that the shark
he looks like a vampire surfer oh this
guy's sick
he does like interview with the vampire
vampire how do they know what kind of
shark bit him if he didn't even realize
he got bit until later
i know he saw the shark like he was like
trying to be like what the [ __ ]
but he was saying that he brushed the
shark off he was like oh
i got bit no so he was saying that when
he got bit the shark like
tasted him and in his words he was like
oh no
this human just went away oh what you
can tell the shark's expression
they're like there's the expressions
like i was not
and this cat's like oh no no yeah i
could tell he wasn't into the meal
that's [ __ ] funny um when we went to
hawaii we swam with the sharks they were
like
uh usually sharks aren't aggressive like
they're not trying to eat humans what it
is is they
because they're certain sharks they have
really bad uh vision
so what they do is they test bite to see
if it's even edible
and if they like it so that's probably
what this guy knows
he's like he bit him and he was like oh
[ __ ] this is nasty i don't like like a
costco sample
yeah maybe that's what it was they like
turtles and seals
not human a lot of uh surfers get big
because they're wearing wetsuits and it
makes them look like seals you wanna
hear something crazy
what uh seals eat sharks what
yes what the [ __ ] up geo
you shut
no this is one a special right now it's
like telling you all the animals that do
eat sharks
and so seals they eat baby sharks
because they know they're going to grow
up
i thought you i pictured like 50 seals
[ __ ] bum rushing a great white shark
that's what i picture
no they're like little baby sharks
they'll come and eat them wow because
they're karma
cute and then and then you can tell from
the great white expression
that it was really scary yeah you really
do look like a shark when you're waiting
thank
i don't like it because you really do
look like a shark thank you
i can get into the mind of it and i'm
saying i'm kind of an actor character
yeah good character work pack it up yeah
but yeah so they're just reporting it
like man he was such a badass he just
got out
what did he drink at the bar that will
really to determine if he's a [ __ ] or
not
sex on the cosmopolitan did you say that
i was making a joke at the same time you
guys made the same joke
we just do the reds yeah i don't know
what they
what they what he ate i don't know i
mean reported in mascot still want to
judge him
um then it was an adios [ __ ]
yeah oh okay that's pretty bad
shark bite let's looks not like nothing
though like that's probably fall off a
skateboard or something
that's what i was thinking like it's
really not hospital worthy because
the thing i'm always thinking about is
like is it worth the money
because hospitals are [ __ ] expensive
yeah i'm like i [ __ ] they're just
gonna wrap me up you know
and he he might not have health care
either like if i got bit
the first thing i would test is like
okay cool didn't affect any of my
fingers
cool not paralyzed in any way did it hit
a main vein yeah i would just bounce
somewhere that's cool but if i'm like
oh [ __ ] i can only move these fingers
like you said it was a shark
you would go to the because i pictured
like the cartoon kind where it looked
like a reese's pieces got cut out of a
human's body
i pictured his whole limb was gone and
he was just like he had a nub
and he's drinking a beer that's a
gangster
that would be sick he's like nothing i
can do about it now yeah
he's like [ __ ] it well there was
recently this
uh this teen teen girl that was surfing
with her dad and
she did get pretty tore up for real oh
wait where how long
she died so she uh i forgot
i don't have that story pulled up but i
forgot where she was from but she was
just surfing with her dad
and one of her legs actually had to be
amputated because there was like pretty
much
nothing left of her leg and like some of
her like i think some of her
like her hands and like her fingers whoa
she got a shark bit
and then it was like mmm this is a tasty
meal yeah like her
expression the expressions yeah because
that's when they like it
yeah yeah the dad had to punch the shark
to finally release her because it was
just attacking him
oh that's the slowest punch ever yeah
because you're in the water bro
yeah you're like you know what so you
get a dream punch and that's special you
know it was crazy how uh orcas kill some
sharks
orcas so orcas they they just eat
straight up live sharks i mean like
adult sharks
what they'll do is since they hunt in a
pack if there's like a shark
kind of close to the surface they'll
just come and tail whack them
yeah it'll knock the shark flying
through the air
and when they come back in like they all
just chomp on his ass they're way bigger
than sharks right
yeah shit's crazy killer wheel shamus
that's what they're called shamu that's
crazy uh dude i was watching this video
of this girl that lost her hand
from uh water skiing she was like
and there's there's a youtube video she
made um yeah she was like she was water
skiing
and then she came up and she had the
rope around her wrist
and she was just chilling and talking
and then i guess like the rope got cut
like caught and she got flung into the
water and then when she came off
actually it was just a nub and like her
hand was gone
that's why it's supposed to be
detachable so you can let go in danger
i know that's why she's stupid onto the
boat and then yeah
oh she was just all set in the water and
then yeah i thought you were gonna say
she was just holding on and her wrist
was so weak and just like
that sounds like some [ __ ] that would
happen to me did she go get a mai tai
after
yes uh uh dude i do water skiing
actually sucks i got this scar
i got like a scar on all three of these
fingers is water skiing you're pretty
damn active
you've done a lot but i suck at it i
suck at it that's the problem
so i basically was surprised i was
trying and falling
my water skied like 500 feet on my
[ __ ] face dude is what happened
like the whole tiger's just like yeah
i'm just like like that and then they're
like you want to go again i'm like no
give me the [ __ ] out of here dude yeah
how are you supposed to stand like how
do they teach you to do it
it's not possible i wakeboarded but i
was dating a guy that was over six feet
and he couldn't stand and he was getting
so pissed because i could stand on the
board and he couldn't stand on the board
wakeboarding like when it's like water
skiing but it's like a snowboard
yeah yeah exactly it's like the
snowboarding of water skiing he doesn't
know how to use his legs
yeah he couldn't get out but i guess
it's hard for tall people
to stand to get out so hard bro that's
why you fell in your face yeah [ __ ] yeah
it's hard
that's what i'm saying i was defending
you oh
thank you yeah i also went hang gliding
do you know i'm pretty active
why you went hang gliding i sure did was
that pretty fun what
i know you're active i called you
actually you know that made the face but
i'm quite i'm quite even more i'm quite
even more active than you perhaps you
thought oh wow i'm just gonna go off a
cliff right yeah yeah
when did you do it where who the [ __ ]
are you dude
the guy is he lying no the guys that you
guys knew the past few years
is not really me i'm i'm actually not i
i like i started going to the gym again
i feel like i'm back now what's the next
sport you're doing
you want to get your skydiving lances
with me and bart no yeah
because i feel like i could die you're
getting your skydiving license she said
she wanted to do it i was like ask joe
to do it and i'll do it too
oh oh you didn't say that i did you said
i'm down let's do it
i am down but i knew you're gonna ask
her oh i didn't get an ask
anyway what do you do you want to go
skydiving uh i'll think about it
[Laughter]
oh what's your next event that you're
doing my next event yeah like your next
thing that you're gonna try i think oh
athletic thing
i have an active active well yeah no oh
well for the gym every day basically is
my current thing but then yeah
i'll figure it out when i when i get
there i'm still like working this stupid
body out
but then once i get to the hot springs
deep creek baby what what
i'm one of the hot springs in august
august 10th that's not with beans
we're getting invited i'm going with
george oh cool
dick george dude george is pretty
interesting he
i just saw him at the gym the other day
and pink dick was like i just came back
from
a 15 day hike yeah yeah he was like
off the grid his photos were really
beautiful and i was like why'd you have
to do that and he's like i want
i wanted my own volition i liked it and
i'm like why would you [ __ ] do that
he told us
i had to walk 16 miles a day and i was
hard to keep up 60 miles a day yeah 16
miles a day and i guess the people he
were
he was with were like pro hikers or
something and so they were like trekking
so far and he was like in the back of
the group but he was like it was fun
though
i would do it again
[Music]
you